it's time to look back at what's been
done and figure out how best to move
forward the second half of 2017 begins
with a highly anticipated state of the
European Union debate Commission
President jean-claude Juncker will set
out the --use priorities highlighting
some of the biggest challenges facing
Europe one of which is the ongoing
migration crisis with more than a
million people reaching Europe Shores
countries on the front line are
struggling to cope under the current
so-called Dublin regulation asylum
seekers are set back to the EU country
these first set foot in an overhaul is
urgently needed as a new rules to offset
deforestation to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions Parliament also wants to cut
the number of carbon credits companies
can buy and support low-carbon
innovation where innovation is also
needed isn't promoting work-life balance
eternity leave parental leave carers
leave flexible working hours these are
some proposals em ups will be focusing
on to improve the rights of working
parents the right of posted workers are
also in the spotlight how can the rights
and working conditions be protected how
long should assignments last how can we
avoid social dumping a reform of the
controversial rules is in the pipeline
while some areas require reform others
need new ones to catch up with fast
changing digital times cookies for
example track our online activities a
new private II regulation should change
the way our online data is protected and
make it easier to accept or refuse
pop-up windows and finally the year's
end will be marked by accolades MEP s
will vote and award the 11th Lok strive
for the best European film another award
the several prize for freedom of thought
to celebrate human rights activists like
these to Yazidi victims of is they were
last year's recipients
[Music]